segundo round en Brasil el candidato
presidencial izquierdista Luis Ignacio
Lula da Silva y el actual presidente
Jair bolsonaro reiniciaron sus campañas
electorales
en la mira los comicios definitivos del
30 de octubre
rodeado de una marea roja Lula recorrió
guarulhos en el estado de Sao Paulo allí
el ex presidente se dirigió a su
simpatizantes y aprovechó para mandarle
una pugna a su contrincante
hay que sacarlo de ahí y poner a alguien
que le gusta el pueblo y le gustan los
hombres las mujeres los niños y los
trabajadores un abrazo compañeros y
hasta la Victoria Si Dios quiere
más al norte en Brasilia bolsonaro se
reunió con varios niños que portaban la
camiseta de la selección nacional El
presidente firmó autógrafos y también
atacó a su rival
si pones a un borracho al frente de
Brasil un tipo sin responsabilidades que
tiene un historial de corrupción un
historial de libertinaje hacia la
familia brasileña de ataques a
sacerdotes y pastores de ataques de las
fuerzas armadas de ataques a la policía
que funcionará
cierto
la Cruzada acusaciones también tuvo
lugar en las redes sociales Twitter fue
el ring donde Lula atacó primero
viajaremos por todo Brasil visitaremos
los estados que tendrán una segunda
vuelta y tendremos debates Vicky
bolsonaro está nervioso me ha estado
maldiciendo pero necesitas saber que
quién quiere ser jefe de estado no puede
estar nervioso
la respuesta de bolsonaro no se hizo
esperar lo que no puede hacer un jefe de
estado es robar vagabundo
según la más reciente encuesta de
datafolia El izquierdista se llevaría un
49% de los votos en la segunda vuelta
venciendo al ultraderechista quien se
llevaría 44% de los sufragios